man whoa Georgia Martin's de Oliveira is
one of Portugal's most famous horsemen a
legendary former bullfighter he now
teaches dressage clinics and he's a very
successful breeder of the country's own
breed the Lucy tano his stud stallion
savio is worth 60,000 euros we
Portuguese are very proud of our Lucy
tano horses they're the calling cards of
a culture that goes back thousands of
years very important culturally as well
as economically economic opinion but
Portuguese breeders are changing the
Lucy tonneaus type it was traditionally
bred for bullfighting driving and
classical dressage but to compete in
modern dressage sports breeders have
altered the size and gait of the horses
Olivera is not pleased with this
development I think it's a shame the
traditional Lucy tano is a very nimble
graceful horse but the dressage
competitions demand a bigger horse acts
to the detriment of this breed in my
opinion when any punto de vista
the revit asia region in the hinterlands
of lisbon is largely agricultural it's
also a famed breeding ground for the
Lucy tano which is an important
traditional element of the area once a
year the otherwise sleepy village of
Golgotha is transformed as horse
breeders from across the country gather
here this National Horse Fair also
attracts interested on lookers
traditions are proudly displayed here
although most of the Luciano's own show
represent the more modern breeding
standards Guga briefly becomes the
center of the Portuguese horse world
peoples all around the world come to see
the the z1000 horse and that's why we
are here every year but what many
visitors don't see is that people here
are breeding too many horses those that
aren't sold are often left to fend for
themselves
this fall was abandoned so Sharon Clark
took it in the British horse lover looks
after neglected horses and tries to find
new homes for them in Portugal as well
as in Britain Germany or France she
cares for 150 horses with the help of
donations
there's many abandoned horses the the
economy in Portugal right now isn't so
good a horse is a luxury item it costs
you money so many people now they just
can't afford to keep them they can't
afford the food or the hay or the vets
so many are just left abandoned to die
and some end up at the slaughterhouse
Sharon knows the spot where horses get
left before they go to slaughter it's
this field here this mayor around 7
years old is very friendly so Sharon
believes she was once well cared for
it's very difficult
she's a beautiful horse
it's a waste it's a big waste it
shouldn't be allowed to happen but it
does and there's thousands like this
that I'd like to save but I can't and
one person
within one year nearly three thousand
Luciano's went to slaughter the breeding
industry surplus Belarmino Figueredo
makes his living selling on these
unwanted animals he can earn up to 100
euros per horse pain anyways come on
people are breeding horses that they can
no longer care for so they call me to
sell the horses to get rid of I go there
we discuss a price and we get the
paperwork that's very important the
horses need to be microchipped
or the slaughterhouses won't take
traders are now asking astronomical
prices for the dressage horses sold at
the market in Bulgaria breeder allagadda
takes a critical view it used to be
about passion you went to the Google
hosts fair to teach the people how well
schooled your horse was today the focus
is just on money it's more about selling
the mentality has changed in there
mentally de
but Oliveira is sticking with his
breeding program focusing on the
original Lucy tano type he still
believes in the old Portuguese
traditions and he knows what an
important role the horses played in the
country's long history